a solemn reminder of the dark days of
russia's past
the commander-in-chief of the armed
forces commemorating defender of the
fatherland day
which honors war veterans and all
russians who lost their lives defending
their country
prior to the wreath-laying ceremony by
the tomb of the unknown soldiers near
the kremlin
president vladimir putin released the
video message to the nation
but with a clear warning for the world
i want to repeat russia's interests and
the security of our people are an
indisputable priority so we will
continue to strengthen and modernize our
army and navy striving to increase their
effectiveness so they fit it out with
the most cutting-edge equipment
an independent polling group says the
majority of russians believe they're
president over 50 percent of people
surveyed at the start of the ukraine
crisis back in december
believe the united states and nato
countries are responsible for increasing
tensions
events like this to honor fallen
soldiers are taking place across the
country but this year's events are
particularly poignant as a threat of war
in ukraine over shadows a day that's
dedicated to remembering the human cost
of war
most here say the thought of war is
simply unimaginable
i wouldn't like the war to start i'd
like all political powers to make
efforts to avoid war and we really hope
there will be no war and it looks like
at the end of the day there will be no
war
i think there will be no war nobody
needs war neither ukraine nor russia as
a rule these are politicians who start
wars they are the only ones who need
wars
i think that we are all slavic people
ukrainians and russians do you need war
i don't need it why would young guys die
people children parents mothers fathers
i think that common sense will prevail
putin says russia is always open for
direct and honest dialogue but has full
confidence in the military
military that will likely include a new
generation of russians who have never
ventured far from home
but must now prepare themselves for the
possibility that they could one day be
back here
just not as visitors paying their
respects to unknown soldiers
a dark and sobering thought on a day
meant to remind the country of the
senselessness of war
doors to jabari al jazeera moscow
well let's look at how the military
strengths of russia and ukraine compare
ukraine has about 209 000 active
military personnel but russia has about
four times that number with more than
900 000 active service members and when
it comes to their reserves ukraine has
another 900 000
trained to a military standard but again
they're outnumbered by russia which has
about 2 million
onto military equipment russia is
clearly a superior force with more tanks
armored vehicles and artillery than the
ukrainian side when it comes to air
power the story is the same russia also
has about 15 times the number of fighter
jets and all of ukraine's current fleet
was built during the cold war
russia's anti-aircraft system the s 400
is said to be one of the strongest
defense systems in the world while
ukraine's own anti-aircraft system is
largely outdated the country's received
a significant amount of anti-aircraft
missiles from latvia and
lithuania well joining us now from
washington dc is charles cupchan he is a
senior fellow at the council on foreign
relations and a professor of
international affairs at georgetown
university
thanks very much uh for being with us so
um on paper it would seem
that uh
ukraine is very much outnumbered and
outmatched here uh from a military uh
standpoint so
what what are its options at this point
if if a larger conflict were to break
out
well i think your description is pretty
accurate
and in some ways the numbers hide the
degree of mismatch and that's simply
because the russian military is not just
bigger but it's better it has much
better equipment it's trained to higher
standards even though the ukrainian army
is much better than it was in 2014
it would not be able to stop russia if
russia decides to invade i think what
we're seeing here by calling up
reservists by getting more support from
outside is an effort to deter russia by
telling putin that if you invade it will
be a bloody affair the costs will be
high but in my mind the biggest
deterrent to putin right now is not
necessarily the war itself but what
comes after does he really want to
invade and occupy a country of 44
million people and deal with
a grassroots insurgency that's likely to
follow that's a much bigger
bite than the actual invasion itself
there's also the issue isn't there of
how this would play
in russia i mean i'm not i'm not sure if
you heard our correspondence report
there but there was a sense there among
many ordinary russians that they don't
want this
to go into a full-blown
uh uh conflict and and and to see uh
more more russians and ukrainians uh
dying this is something that would not
that would not play well uh but back
home in russia is that um
a deterrent is uh would that be acting
as a deterrent
as well as in in putin's thinking
yes and that's why
the ukrainian effort nato's effort to
raise the costs matters because putin is
doing a cost benefit analysis now
most of his actions to date in his
neighbors
in georgia
in moldova
in
nagorno-karabakh even in syria have been
relatively limited not that many russian
casualties if there are lots of body
bags coming home that could make the
story quite different and you have to
keep in mind that the west is going to
impose very significant severe sanctions
against russia that will affect the
quality of life in russia so both when
it comes to body bags and when it comes
to sanctions putin really will be taking
a huge step into the dark you mentioned
the sanctions there how damaging could
those sanctions to be could could be to
russia given that
um it seems to have prepared well for
this with this large uh uh foreign
foreign exchange reserves um and this is
this is figured into putin's thinking
hasn't it that the west would respond uh
with sanctions uh and and he's made
preparations for that so how damaging
would they be in the long run
well you're right to note that putin has
a big rainy day fund it's about 630
billion he's also taken steps since 2014
to try to immunize the russian economy
in part by building domestic sources of
production in part by deepening his ties
to china
but depending on the the sanctions that
the west imposes i think you are looking
at a very big hit to the russian economy
we're talking about taking russian banks
out of commercial markets preventing
russia from floating its own debt on
international markets banning the sale
of technology that keeps russian
consumers able to buy things like cell
phones maybe turning off the spigot when
it comes to energy although that could
be uh more painful to europe than than
to russia so it depends upon what menu
of sanctions
is is is chosen for but we are looking
at a potential major hit to the russian
economy
good to get your perspective on this uh
charles kupchan joining us there from
washington
my pleasure